[Music]
for years there have been calls for more
diversity in the technology industry but
a recent study found there's actually
been
very little progress black professionals
make up just five percent of the tech
workforce and three percent of executive
positions
researchers also found that from 2014 to
2020 black representation increased
by only one percentage point the founder
of several tech startups including one
valued at more than a billion dollars
is tackling the industry's issues head
on as carter evans reports he is
focusing on offering free courses
on college campuses if the tech talent
pipeline isn't working
we decided that we were going to rebuild
that pipeline
michael ellison knows firsthand how
difficult it is to break into
the tech industry he grew up with a
single mom in rural maine
and was homeless at times but he
excelled at math and was encouraged to
study computer science in college
i was sitting in a classroom spending 30
hours to complete assignment that
kids standing next to me were taking say
two to four hours
i just felt like i wasn't smart enough
to major in cs he dropped out of the
program
after his freshman year if you're an
underrepresented minority
if you're coming from a low income
background the system's not designed for
you
he says one of the main problems is that
underrepresented minorities are more
likely to attend computer science
programs with outdated classes in
limited resources
what if you're a computer science
student and you're
attending a school where your professors
can't pass the technical interviews but
you don't have enough people to teach
the basic stuff let alone the cutting
edge technologies that the companies
want
ellison eventually got his degree and
worked with startups that focused on
tech education
one built a training program for
companies like facebook google and
netflix called codepath
and he realized it could also fill in
the gaps in college curricula
now students in 60 schools nationwide
can take
courses on the industry's most in-demand
skills like app development and cyber
security
i wanted to be able to learn mobile
development for ios
because i feel like that's a great skill
to have today is a panel and we have
some
people in the industry talking to us we
just finished up with lab
we discussed the assignment for this
week
and it looks like we're going to build a
clone of instagram
i think it's looking pretty good
codepath also helps prepare
students for their first tech job
interview more than half of those in the
program are minority or first generation
college students
including 20 year old fazia alibiosu who
studies computer science in maryland
i was hooked i really was because i
learned about android development which
is something my school doesn't have
courses about
and i also got to like talk to people
who are already in
industry like android engineers it's
been so helpful to know
what companies are looking for
especially when you don't know any
computer scientists
in your life if we're not being
intentional about inclusion then we're
probably
unintentionally excluding stanford
teacher cynthia lee created a course
called
race and gender in silicon valley she
says programs like
codepath can help address the main
factors that have hurt minority job
candidates trying to break into the
industry
the most important would be the hiring
interview process as well as
the places where recruiters look how
likely are codepath graduates to get
jobs
if you are say a black computer science
student at codepath
43 times more likely to be able to get a
job at one of the most competitive tech
companies
and he says landing a job is just the
first step
we unapologetically are not just trying
to get people in somewhere
we're trying to get them can you lead a
technology company
can you be someone who's founding tech
startups
if you want to talk about racial equity
you have to talk about systemic change
for cbs this morning carter evans san
francisco
43 times more likely to get a job that's
an effective program
that typing you hear is people trying to
figure out how to sign up for codepath
i've always thought learning the code
would be fascinating yeah there's a lot
of smart people in that story make me
feel very inadequate
yeah really i loved her jumping out of
her skin